as I'm not even live Wow all right all
right so I basically just did like the
whole intro not realizing I'm live so
welcome back against feels very strange
saying all this again but welcome back I
don't know if you guys are gonna hear
this for a second time but heck let's
just do it again to make sure a quick
review almonds got the almonds I have
the water because you need you're gonna
need that I have a discord channel for
you guys so we can all you know get
together and learn how to do VFX
together and stay organized and yeah I
was just going over this thing and
basically this discord chat nor this
discord channel there's a link to it in
the description of this live stream
right now go there join up we can go
over stuff like project progress here
you guys can post your progress as we do
these tutorials someone also brought up
the idea of using an Instagram hashtags
that we can all post our stuff on
Instagram as well if you guys would
prefer that we can figure out what that
hashtag would be probably in the project
progress tab we have a tutorial
suggestions tab and in the tutorial
suggestions tab is pretty obvious you
know throw down all the ideas that you
want to learn all the different things
that you want to know about in the
tutorial suggestions tab you know do you
guys want to learn about modeling
texturing lighting photography After
Effects whatever you guys are feeling we
can go over all those suggestions in
that tab and then we have stream
suggestions and that's basically like
how can I make this a better experience
for you guys better mic better quality
better better camera you know special
segments giveaways whatever you guys are
feeling you know we can talk about that
in the stream suggestions tab and
honestly if you guys have any discord
channel suggestions you can throw
those in there too but um yeah what are
we doing today guys we we modeled this
tank last week and if you guys weren't
here last week this is a tank from
castle in the sky it's just a frame I
grabbed and basically we modeled the
heck out of this thing we got about
halfway and I took it most of the way
during the week you know there's still
some details I could add but this will
be great this will be a really really
nice tank the texture we're gonna grunge
this thing up it's gonna be gross it's
gonna be little maybe a little rusted a
little scratched up the edges are gonna
be jacked up we're gonna get this
camouflage going we're gonna do the
whole deal you know we got some glass up
here I'm using octane personally but I
hear that Arnold and redshift are very
similar if you guys are in blender I
think there's the there's like the e V
live real-time renderer I don't know if
Eevee has some materials but this
segment here this live stream should
pertain to all areas and all programs as
far as texturing goes these concepts are
things that you guys can use in any
other program you guys will see how I
text or something how I start and how I
get more detailed and more detailed last
week we were talking about starting
general and getting more detailed more
specific more specific until you have
like you know an awesome model or an
awesome character or an awesome tank any
black man that must have taken forever
but really it's just you know like
little tiny pieces like this that add up
and add up and I was actually talking
with a good friend Ian Hubert's earlier
this week and he was saying how his
stuff is basically just adding cylinders
and squares on top of each other and let
me pull up Ian's Instagram for you guys
so you can see what I'm talking about
he is a master in blender my goodness
this guy is super inspirational let's
see let's get his Instagram pulled up
here
there we go for some reason it's in
Russian I don't know why but like check
this stuff out that's one of his
tutorials he does these things called
lazy tutorials and they're the best it's
all in blender you guys should check
this guy out but he does stuff like look
at this look at this this is all just
cubes and and cylinders moved around and
he starts general and gets more detailed
more detailed more detailed and textures
this stuff really quickly it's really
incredible you know this is all this
stuff is like very similar concepts here
you see cylinders you see rectangles
that are beveled right you know it's
just detailed and the beveling and he's
building it up and spending the time and
adding these pieces on top of each other
to make these really cool-looking pieces
of art here and that's the same thing
that we're doing is the same concept
same idea is we're starting with
something very general and we're
building on top of that so if I hadn't
said it already
we're texturing this tank today that is
the goal of today's stream but how are
you guys doing let's check in here what
is up everybody thank you for joining
max thanks thanks for being here
Luth wick yes never forget the almonds
can't I forget the almonds healthy
snacks guys so the discord link okay so
you guys just discord link expired let
me see if we can fix that real quick I
thought I already fixed it though all
right I'm gonna fix this discord link
for you guys right now let's see so
let us see here how do we do this we
want to invite edit the invite link
sorry guys bear with me
okay
almost done here let's see let's see
discord link should work now give the
discord link a try let me know in the
comments here if that worked for you
guys and we'll fix it if it doesn't so
again I'm using octane inside of cinema
4d to make these textures these are
textures that you guys I'm sorry these
are concepts that you guys will be able
to use over any program so it doesn't
matter if you're using blender Maya you
know whatever any of that stuff you guys
will be able to follow along alright let
us jump in alright it looks like it
works because I'm getting these little
notifications here which I need to
figure out a way to close this cuz may
ask me popping off alright guys
it's working so here we go let's jump in
first things first
what's the most general thing about this
tank it's probably the camouflage so
let's start with that
in octane you have a few options you can
make a diffuse material you can make a
glassy material and usually most of the
time I'm working with glassy materials
so I'm going to make a new material and
let's render our scene here so we can
see what we're doing perfect
awesome alright so we have our new glass
material and we will throw that on the
tank and we're gonna do this in a couple
different steps here so we're gonna have
basically we're gonna be building up
these different building blocks as far
as the texturing goes we're gonna have a
like an outer layer basically like the
paint layer we're gonna have the the
base metal foundation that will be what
we see on the corners or if there's a
scratch in the tank you're gonna see
through the paint down to the metal
we're gonna want to have like dirt build
up inside of the crevices right we might
do a dust layer on top and then you
could even do another layer on top of
that like grungy kind of like oil smears
or something anything else anything else
yeah there's dirt on the inside and then
we could probably do on top of
everything dirt over and over the entire
thing like the whole thing's been like a
in a battle or a sandstorm or something
we really want to grunge up this whole
tank and make it look like it has seen
things you know it's it's been to war a
few times it's not gonna be a clean tank
alright sweet thank you guys for the
discord the discord advice Here I am
learning the process this is only the
third time first time using the discord
so thank you guys for all the advice
we're gonna get this stream nice and
nice and spicy real real good like are
the panels extruded parts or separate
shapes placed in on the tank they're
actually separate pieces placed on the
tank and what I did was used the
geometry of the like
you know the main cube we made last week
and I basically just popped off these
pieces here like that separated them you
can still see the foundation underneath
right but you have these little panels
on top and let me see if I can get these
notifications off here really appreciate
you guys joining this thing but let me
see if I can follow mamiya's advice and
turn these notifications to something
else here bear with me for one sec sir
server notification settings see now now
you getting that scratchy throat from
the almonds good thing I got my water
right here
all right good times very very very good
times all right I hate to be doing
technical stuff here that doesn't have
to do with the tutorial during the
stream so I might have to figure out how
to set these notifications to another
setting later hmm hmm well if you guys
have specific a specific way of how to
do that of how to change server
notifications for only mentions to all
messages then just type in all caps in
the chat and I will figure that out
goodness let's get to texturing this
thing guys that's why we're here that is
why we are here all right so we have our
glossy material over this tank let's get
this camo going so here's a little
here's a little tip little trick for you
guys basically the way I'm gonna do the
camouflage is with a noise map so you
drag that right into the diffuse Channel
and already it's looking like but it's
looking horrible so a couple issues
first off let's um let's tweak the noise
settings so we can see what we're doing
the mapping is wrong the the the
contrast in the noise is wrong the noise
pattern is wrong so let's let's fix the
contrast first so we can see what we're
doing I'm gonna crank the contrast up to
100 okay so you have some parts that
look normal but you have some parts that
look totally stretched and you have some
parts that are really small the UV
mapping is completely off so one way
that we can fix that and honestly the
the the best way I can think of is to
make a projection tab
and if you click that right there it'll
automatically be applied to the little
projection node right there you can also
drag it from the left over here and
connect it manually like that so now we
can change the projection method right
you're gonna drop down this little thing
and usually I said at the box and that
basically fixes the issue but if you
look closely here you can see how the
noise pattern kind of it doesn't connect
right here you see that how one edge is
different from the other edge same here
on the bolt you know like you can really
see this especially here right you can
see how this bottom is black and then as
soon as you get to this this wall here
it's white that's not good if you look
closely you can really tell yeah right
here boom so how do we fix that well
it's as easy as switching to another
projection method so instead of box I've
found recently that XYZ to uvw totally
solves the problem and you guys can see
now how we don't have that issue anymore
or it so actually it's a lot like you
can maybe you can see it on this bolt
here right but generally it actually is
not bad I think it totally works
everything is a bit more uniform so now
you can see our tank looks like white
noise on an old TV and that's no good so
now we need to mess with the we've
messed with the contrast the contrast is
good we've messed with the projection
now we need to mess with the scale and
then the noise type so let's get the
scale up first and the way I like to do
that is make a little click this uvw
transform button and that will do the
same deal it'll make a new little
transform tab you can also drag it from
here on to the transform tab
and you will have the ability to scale
the noise like this you can really scale
it up like that and let's keep going
let's go to eight that's looking pretty
good now look at them look at the
pattern here it's kind of like a tiger
stripe look right so that's gonna be in
our noise type right so the contrast is
clearly maxed out you don't see any
moments here where the tan and the brown
are blending together it's just one or
the other so that's the contrast we have
that pretty good but you can see how our
pattern doesn't really look right so
whether again blender or 3ds Max or
cinema 4d or Maya I'm sure you have a
similar thing you have a similar noise
tab and you can change your types of
noise so unfortunately in octane we only
have four choices and more more on that
in a minute we can we can get around it
pretty easily but let's just go through
these we have a turbulence noise and if
you crank the gamma you can kind of see
how that is affecting the model here and
thank you guys for joining this discord
server it's gonna really help out we're
gonna get on the same page here so
that's the gamma right it gives you a
bit more the black a bit more the white
what is circular so that's more like
little circles a little little broccoli
crowns alright and that that's that's
not what we're going for what are what
are chips okay interesting they're like
little little chips I guess you can
invert that it looks interesting but
still not the same it's not the right
look we're not going after that this
could be useful for chipping away the
paint and revealing metal underneath and
we'll do that later but basically
there's a little hidden tray
here inside of cinema4d and when you're
using octane you're using specifically
octane noise here right that's what this
is
same deal and you only have those four
options but if you guys want to use
cinema for DS noise thank you for
joining the server guys much appreciated
let's see let's see if we can change
these notification settings you can
right-click the server on the Left panel
go to notification settings there let's
try it sweet thank you
danga appreciate you dude fix the issue
very fast
awesome awesome thanks for joining the
server guys let's let's keep going in
here so how do we access cinema for DS
noise to unlock tons more noise well
let's go into if you just double click
the little material down here you'll
come into this viewer and this is the
normal viewer that most people know I
personally like using the node viewer
it's a lot easier to see all the things
you have involved in your texture so if
you guys can get out of this like
ListView and into this node view right
here when you're when you're doing
textures the sooner the better get into
this node view as soon as you can
because you're really gonna be able to
tell all of the the pieces going on that
build up your texture and it's gonna get
to a lot of stuff I think when I did if
you guys have never seen it let's see
I'll just show you an example
this video so with this video I I'm on
the robot and I textured the robot and
basically you can see like the chest
plate right it has like it's all
scratched up and everything and each one
of these little pieces is a it's a
different these cats are going nuts over
here I got I got a new kitten and he's
just going crazy so apologies if you
guys can hear them in the background but
basically we got a lot of textures going
on this thing and each piece you know
there's a camouflage pattern here and
here and here this is a different kind
of metal than this kind of metal here
it's backpack is a different kind of
metal the gun metal is a little
different metal there's a lot of
different kind of textures here and a
lot of these textures are made up from
two or three or sometimes four different
textures such as like this one here you
see there's like the black the black
paint and then when it's scratched out
you have that silver underneath you know
same here when you're seeing these like
scratched out pieces in the corners or
on the edges that's made up of at least
two different materials because you're
seeing two different materials so this
was a very complicated texturing system
and will kind of get into that a little
bit with this tank tutorial so let's get
to that noise we've gotten sidetracked
here all you wanted to go all you want
to do is well let's delete that noise go
to the diffuse tab and you're gonna hit
this little drop down and just select
noise perfect so now your noise you have
all these options under noise and look
at all the different kinds of noise we
have all of this and I hadn't tested
this yet so let's see if we can get the
UV mapping right because if we can't get
the UV mapping right then we might just
have to use the octane noise but um
let's see what let's see what we can do
here let's crank up the
contrast okay and now I know it has UV
options in the actual like if you click
the the texture up here you can change
the UV mapping to cubic but this is
getting tricky because now it's
basically using okay yeah there we go
that's kind of working so let's see if
we can't scale this up hmm yeah that
doesn't look right it's like tiled
strangely let's see
yep so I'm going between these different
projections here and none of them are
really looking good here I wish I could
just use the octane texture projection
tab and throw that into this noise but I
don't think I can do that
so we might just have to use the octane
noise here which isn't the end of the
world yeah well
man
I wish that'd be awesome
it'd be nice let's just take a step back
let's use the octane noise crank up our
contrast throw in the texture projection
and the transform and let us choose our
colors so we have we can sample this
image here and by the way guys I have
basically I got this picture from a list
of movie stills that I've collected over
the years and I actually have that
download link included in the stream
description as well so you can download
that I did upload it last week this it
might be it might be dead by now but I
will include that again in at the end of
this process so let's grab these colors
this is looking like alright so I'm
gonna grab gradient here boom if you
just click and drag right until this
line turns yellow let go and voila we
have black and white right here so if we
change black to say yellow it will
change the black to yellow same for the
white if we want it blue it'll do that
too so all you have to do is select
those colors with the dropper that tan
and let's see like this brown right here
yeah there you go
looking pretty sweet
let's get that let's get that Brown
right so basically you want to sample it
from not the reflective part or not the
shadow part but something flat something
like a bit more in between yeah I like
that that feels good so yeah let's get
this let's get this noise pattern right
so octaves right that's basically like
how detailed this thing is gonna look so
if we zoom in here and we go to our
noise node here and you mess with the
octaves if you take it down to one you
can see how it kind of simplifies the
pattern and if you take it up to 10 or
beyond it makes the pattern more
detailed and more intricate now what
we're referencing here is kind of a
smooth type of noise so we'll probably
want to go low on the octave count there
down to one or two one or two either one
could work and now Omega basically I
don't know exactly what it does but it I
know that it makes it more detailed it
breaks it up a little bit more so you
can see here with if you throw your
Omega down to zero you have this but if
you throw your Omega down to one it kind
of breaks up your pattern a bit more and
again if we're referencing this it's not
really broken up they're more just like
tiger stripes running down the model so
we'll take the Omega down to zero and
that'll give us a basic kind of
camouflage to look right here
sweet very nice very nice and with the
transform tab here you can kind of slide
the texture around the tank
you're gonna transform it right t4
transform you're just kind of moving it
until you get a pattern that works nice
for you
all right how's everybody doing you
could always convert your map nodes to
bitmap for sharing not modular but it
depends on your pipeline what you're
trying to do yeah totally agree totally
agree
do you use substance substance painter
in my workflow I was actually really
into a substance designer for a little
bit and that's something that I really
really want to learn I learned a lot
when I was working in that and it's
basically substance designer if you guys
don't know is a program where you can
create anything you want any texture you
want
it's a texturing program you can create
any texture you want based off of black
and white maps so anything that as black
goes down anything that's white goes up
so you can make really detailed like
rocky patterns you can make tile you can
make wood slats you can make a whole
bunch of stuff it's really really cool
so that's actually something that if you
guys want to learn more of I would love
to learn as well we could go to the
discord chat the discord channel and
under tutorial suggestions just write
down substance designer or substance
painter and we can get into that alright
so we have our camouflage look here but
you can see how it's like super
reflective right here and that's not
what we really want cuz this tank here
it's kind of reflective you can tell by
its like reflecting something down here
um and it is metal so it's reflective
but it's not like a mirror you know it's
more it's more rough and here I'll show
you guys what I mean basically you can
go to the roughness tab and crank this
setting and it's gonna smooth out those
reflections you can crank it all the way
up but I like just a little bit you know
so it feels feels about right and it's
the difference between say like this
Bose speaker right here you can see how
it's reflective but you're not gonna see
your your face in this thing you know
what I mean
it's it's expanding and spreading out
the reflection just like we did here on
this tank we cranked the roughness a bit
another example would be like you know
this glass of water the reflections are
sharper you know you can see you might
be able to see your face in this for
example right so this reflection isn't
rough it's very it's the opposite of
that
all right so for an added detail though
you want parts of the model that are
more rough than others so it'd be like
the equivalent of if you put your
handprint on a glass your handprint is
gonna smudge up the reflection a bit
right it's gonna break it up a bit and
that's what we want to do to this tank
so you can do a couple things you can
use another noisemap so let's do that
let's drag that in and let's throw
[Music]
eventually we're gonna throw this
noisemap into the roughness tab right
here but so we can so that we can see
what we're doing let's throw it in the
diffuse tab just for now we're gonna
want to include it in the texture
projection we made so this texture
projection can be going to both noise
maps we're gonna want our own transform
node for that right so we'll make a new
one by clicking that button there or by
just dragging it from up here into the
transform tab and with this one we're
not going to want 100% contrast we're
gonna want parts that are more rough
than others
so let's see yeah probably something
around around there and this is when we
can start messing with the Omega we can
set that to like one because now it's
gonna look like fingerprints or like you
know people have been
cleaning it and wiping it down that kind
of stuff you know and let's crank the
octaves let's maybe go to 10 that might
be a little much I think 5 was pretty
sweet and let's take the contrast back
down something like yeah something like
that and then just for a little bit of
added detail let's basically throw like
a levels on it you know if you guys ever
work in After Effects or Photoshop
you'll use levels to crank the contrast
of an image and let's get let's make
just a couple parts here really dark so
how let's see how would we do this we
just want something like that yeah
that feels pretty sweet perfect so we'll
use this map right here
and we'll plug this into our roughness
tab and you can see hopefully that when
we zoom in here that it's not entirely
rough or opaque but you can see a bit of
detail here let me let me just get the
right angle on this zoom in here let's
make it more extreme so that we can see
what what's going on
we will crank the let's crank the
contrast on this there you go you see
that you see how it's like super shiny
here but it's like way more opaque or
not opaque but way more rough on the
other opposite side and if you
right-click and solo your node you can
see what actually is going on so it
looks like here let's see it looks like
black is no roughness and white is
completely rough so with that in mind
let's just kind of like tweak that a
little bit so it's not entirely opaque
or rough and we have a bit it's more in
the gray right this is making any sense
kind of like that yeah so you do that
way or what you could do is use any
pictures or any like textures that you
download and use that and actually I
have one that I use all the time and
it's from a guy named Cornelius dam
wreck and he has these free like smudge
assets they're super they're like Tyla
Bowl and everything right and these are
really really nice because it looks like
finger prints and stuff he's got this
one more like a fingerprint kind of vibe
here and you can mix these together
right so this looks more like dirt
splatter and this one is like maybe
raindrops or stains or something and you
can mix all these together using a mix
node in octane so let's let's do that
hopefully this won't crash octane last
time it did I'm just gonna drag these
guys into the program and there you go
so basically what we'll do is well throw
this into the diffuse tab again just so
we can see what we're doing
we'll give it the same projection node
so that it's spread across properly and
let's move that into the roughness tab
reconnect our diffuse and if we start to
crank the gamma which is basically kind
of like contrast you can see the
difference here and it's very subtle
it's very very subtle but see you can
you can see it there it looks like
grease you know let's combine some of
these let's um let's see what it looks
like if we combine these so I'll take
another one from this guy we use
fingerprint smudge let's do the
scratched one drag that in we'll give it
the same projection again so the
projection is correct and what we'll do
now and again I'm throwing it in the
diffuse tab so we can see what we're
doing right you can see all the all this
stuff right so there's that one and then
there's this one and we want to mix
these together how would we do that a
couple different ways in octane you can
mix them with a mix node so if we'll
drag that down you have texture 1 and
texture 2 and it's as simple as dragging
the two textures you want to mix into
that little box there and then we'll
connect that to the diffuse tab and now
you can see it's a mixture of both of
those together they're just like 50
percent opacity stacked right on top now
if you use a float node which is up here
drag that into the amount you can choose
which texture you see so right now it's
at 0.5 right in the middle if we go to 0
it's going to be it looks like texture
node one or the other one I don't know
exactly how to tell without having to
pull these in and out or if you set it
to one the float amount it'll go to the
other texture 0.5 blends them perfectly
together you do it a different way
because we don't really have any true
blacks or true whites here it's more in
the gray which can be good for what
we're doing let's let's see what that
looks like it's a little you know not as
extreme as I'd like so one thing you
could do is use a multiply node and if
you're an After Effects or Photoshop you
know that multiply takes away the white
so let's let's put the multiply node in
the diffuse channel there you go you can
actually see how that's working there
with the black and we'll put in one and
two and there now they're stacked on top
of each other and the blacks are shining
through really strong put that in the
roughness that looks cool I'm down for
that
and if you right click the multiply node
you can see how it's you know you can
see those two stacked on top of each
other and solo it right and if you want
to throw a gradient on top of that you
can do that so basically you'd have to
right-click and solo that and instead of
black what if you just set it to a dark
gray and that's basically going to push
and pull your roughness values if white
is come is like a mirror and you don't
want it to be quite a mirror you can
take your white and bring it down to an
off-white and that'll kind of rough it
up a little bit more so that's just the
way to play with these black and white
levels anything that's black is super
rough anything that isn't black or
or rather white is is not rough at all
and anything Gray's in between so you
can use those fingerprint smudges you
can use noise to do that so let's let's
move on I think that looks really nice
let's check the comments how are you
guys doing yes save often guys save
often sweet thanks again guys for doing
this really appreciate you guys and it's
cool to see you guys leaving comments
and everything let me throw the link to
the discord in the is the chat here
boom there's the discord channel for you
guys if you if you hadn't found it yet
okay
let's keep moving
so next all right we got our camo we
have the smudge enos on the tank it's
not you know we can actually scale it up
let's try that it's al it's kind of
small so we could do that by soloing
that layer and okay the mapping is wrong
there obviously the mappings wrong let's
fix that in a second let's see let's see
yeah let's scale this up so we will make
our own transform node for both of those
smudge layers and we'll scale it up
make sure to unsolo the gradient sweet
and then let's fix the well actually is
the mapping really that bad let's just
double-check that yes the mapping is off
okay so it looks like the mapping is off
for the smudge layer so that would be
the projection tab there and there okay
so let's make a new projection tab and
set it the box and that looks good to me
and we'll do the same for the other one
boom that looks normal now cool so we
can drag that back to the roughness and
there are diffuse down awesome
okay moving on let's get some texture in
the actual metal because nothing is
actually flat right
this is totally flat and does not look
right so there would be a bit of texture
to that like a physical like in the
actual geometry of the thing it would
actually be a little bit bumpy right or
scratched
so let's mess with that let's go and
search like do a Google search for tank
Armour because when you're texturing it
is super imperative to reference stuff
you need to actually have some
real-world reference to see what's going
on if you're just going off the top of
your head you know maybe at some point
you'll be good at that
and you can even get away with that but
you know at the end of the day the
closer if you want to get like
photo-real textures you're gonna want to
reference photo real stuff and I'm
looking at images of tanks here on
Google and none of them are on none of
them are really close enough they're all
just kind of like the full tank but yeah
the idea here is you want to reference
something you can be guessing all day
but if you can give yourself like a
direction to go down say like this was
our reference for the tank otherwise
we'd have to draw it ourselves and
figure it out it's a lot easier with a
reference right you don't have to do the
brain work you just have to do like okay
well what are these shapes and how do I
make them and it's the same for
texturing if you if you can reference an
actual texture then that's what it's all
about that's what I did for the Boston
Dynamics robot I referenced actual
actual you know the Boston Dynamics or
the boss sorry so waited for the boss
town dynamics robot and I referenced
Boston Dynamics robots for the materials
let's keep looking for tank Armour
metal armor
hmmm let's try an Armour texture okay
Armour texture looks like it works it's
a lot of like chainmail stuff this is a
good reference here like something like
this it's very grungy it's scratched up
I think that'd be something
yeah like the the rust here in the edges
that's really nice but let's just try
this with some noise maps let's go in
here and once again we'll be using our
diffuse channel for our noise to see
what we're actually doing and then we
will apply it to the bump tab down here
so let us sum let's try some stuff here
okay let's do you know what what I like
to do if you guys already have a
subscription to this website it is one
of the best websites in the world for
texturing and it is mega scans dot s e
and you will find all the textures you
guys need yeah this spot is the best you
have this C they have it they have like
a imperfections tab where you can get
all these different likes smudges and
grunge pieces and drips and scratches
and all that another good one is polygon
comm ran by Andrew price who is the
blender guru if you guys are looking for
good blender tutorials he is the man and
he has look at all these textures man
they so these are all probably made in
substance yeah you can see the little
substance tab here same for some of this
wood right it's made in substance
but you can you can do like photoscan
stuff he has lots of snow and rocks
he's got metal right this is good stuff
really really good stuff see how this
metal here like there looks like there's
a bit of texture to it and if you go to
like mega scans or something you can see
you can go to their metal tab and see
what they have
let's do metal yeah like this kind of
stuff you see how there's there's
texture to this it's not just a flat
piece you know that's that's a really
good one actually so I have some of
those textures I'll be using some of
that but let's see if we can't just do
it with noise because if we can do it
for free
that would be better right alright so
let's grab a noise map octane noise map
here drag it into the diffuse let's pipe
in our texture projection into the
projection tab so that's alright we're
gonna want our own transform tab it's
gonna be smaller let's set the contrast
to like I don't know 5 right now maybe
10 and let's make this smaller so we'll
go 0.5 0.3 maybe even and let's switch
it to turbulence and get our contrast
right maybe you work the gamma and this
is all basically we're trying to get
like a rough look on this thing more
granular kind of noise here we can crank
the octaves up to 10 and that's really
gonna help break things up a bit let's
see I don't know how it looks like wavy
wormy lookin patterns so let's try
circular bring the gamma down and see
what we're working with that looks more
like clouds
that could be nice actually so let's try
one of those let's let's throw into the
bump tab and see what it looks like yeah
not really fan not really a fan it's not
um it just looks kind of cloudy so what
I'm probably gonna do you in this case I
would usually use like a mega scans
texture but let's just for the sake of
experiment see if we can't get closer to
something like that metal
let's try chips see what chips does and
we'll Solo our node and that's a good
way to see what we're doing here
messing with the transform here here we
go
so I'm just kind of pushing and pulling
these numbers until we get something
that looks nice
so I'm still not seeing much here and it
could be our contrast if we crank that
up a bit you know we might be able to
see something there but it's really not
it's really not looking like I want it
to look so in this case I am gonna use
mega scans or you guys can use polygon
polygons a really good one and I'm sure
there's some other good free texture
places to get free textures as well if
you guys know of any feel free to throw
it in the little little chat window off
to the right here
and let's check in how's everybody doing
I feel like I've been talking for the
last hour
all right
broccoli bill this is just fun man I
love texturing I love modeling I love
working in CG so this is a chance for me
to share my knowledge with you guys
yay we got the EU stream I wanted to get
a time that worked for you guys over
there I know everyone was staying up
late last time so thank you for joining
Rasmus yes yeah you can totally use mega
scans in blender absolutely Ralph
okay so Ralph we have been texturing
this tank we have a studio ghibli tank
right here and we have been texturing it
working on getting a nice grungy look
right now we're still on the kind of the
base paint layer and we're working on
the bump and the the texture of it the
actual like physical texture of this
thing and then we'll get into grungy it
up and that's my favorite part I really
can't wait to get into that stuff rough
wick you put down see CEO textures CG
bookcase and texture Haven those are
probably places you can get free
textures thanks for that umm what else
what else guys let's get some almonds
Ruth Wix says most Triple A games today
use it already and recently The Lion
King movie is it as well
unreal bought the company always talking
about mega scans unreal bought the
company and made all the 10,000 plus
assets and textures free for unreal
users yes
unreal that's another program I really
want to learn it's free the textures in
this case on Meg scans are free for
unreal the heck was that so anyway yeah
check out mega skins it's awesome
I'm gonna cheat and I'm gonna use manga
skins
let's look at their let's look at their
metal so this one's really nice the only
thing I don't like about it though are
these seams because our our tank already
has seams they might be small enough so
that you don't really see them but let's
keep scrolling and see if we can't find
something else this isn't bad and again
I'm just looking for the normal maps the
bump maps right the color we we already
have a color for our tank we have our
camo I don't like this because it has
those little like folds in them so let's
keep looking for something ooh ooh this
is a good one this is a really really
good one right here might have to steal
that this is good look at this plating
you can see how it like this is so
awesome I love I love this website so
much about this this is good this is
really good I like that
and you can mix these together too I
literally feel like a kid in a candy
store on this website I go here I like I
check this as much as I check like
Facebook or Instagram yeah there's like
this little micro grain texture in here
that just is so nice that one maybe not
so much it's a little it's a little too
specific I think same for this one like
that's pretty rusty um what about this
one these are all not bad guys
okay I'm gonna grab a couple of these
bear with me as I grab a couple all
right let's do like this one and let's
see
let's do this one sorry I knows you I
know you guys can't see this I'm just
quickly trying to download like three of
them I got one more left here
all right
perfect so I got three of them here and
let's unpack these and figure out how we
can use them for our tank all right
sweet okay so we're back in got my
textures from mega scans you can get up
in polygons you can get up from those
free with free websites let's get in
here and see if we can't throw down some
actual texture on top of our texture
here alright so if you right-click the
like main texture and hit auto arrange
it will auto arrange them for you and if
you right-click like the first little
bump piece here or the first piece in
the hierarchy you can select the
hierarchy and just move that whole piece
down same for the roughness and you know
just to get a little bit of space in
here it'll help you organize things
perfect alright let's get rid of our
bump map and let's see what we got here
so we can use this which is like I don't
if you guys can see it with the YouTube
compression but it is a detailed little
bump map there so I'll bring that in and
actually I'm gonna start with normal the
normal map because that actually bump is
fake bump kind of simulates the light
hitting your model and kind of just
simulates a bit more of detail and more
geometry but with normal it actually is
as far as I understand it's a bit more
I don't know realistic or it as actually
shifting the geometry a little bit and
then displacement actually like really
moves the geometry of your model and we
don't want really want to do
displacement for this right now
I think normal normal will totally work
and I'll show you guys what I mean I'm
gonna drag that map in here I'm gonna
drag it into the normal tab and
hopefully pretty immediately you guys
should be able to see a difference here
let's get the projection
right we'll set that to XYZ to uvw that
doesn't work we'll set it's a box that's
looking good okay so if we solo that you
can see it's very small and it's very
faint so we'll throw transform on there
we'll scale it up to like two yep
and you can kind of see here what's
going on if i zoom way in you guys see
that
now there's actual texture to these
armor plates because of that normal map
and again you can do it with noise and
these are very tiny details you may not
see but I think they they do build up
over time here let's scale it up again
let's go to three and then you could
actually grab a float node and bring it
into the power and said that - like - so
you're kind of really doubling it and
there you can see we have an armor
texture there that looks that looks
sturdy yeah that's awesome
very nice very nice
so we might be getting some mapping
issues like right in here and I don't
know entirely how to fix that other than
just kind of like playing around with
the projection now X Y Z 2 u VW usually
works for me maybe if we start tweaking
these settings on transform or rotation
might help us
hmm yeah no that's really working
I feel like box was box was the best one
and I think also it's gonna help when we
apply the material to the specific
objects versus you know versus like the
whole tank right see we're applying it
to the entire tank when we start
applying it to the actual like hull or
more specifically we start applying it
to the armor pieces
I think the mapping will even itself out
but for now let's let's just change that
to box because that's probably the best
method so far because again we start we
start general and we get more detailed
right so we're still building out this
layer let's um let's mess with another
bump map here or normal map and that
will be let's see here
[Music]
this one yeah what does this one look
like slightly different pattern and same
for this one slightly different pattern
let's try this one here and really I'm
just building these up for detail right
this is a new normal map I'll apply the
same projection transform and power and
when I switch these out take a look at
the pattern here and you'll see how the
pattern shifts and we get something
different oh crap
it disappeared one second
boom there you go they can see it's like
chipped metal or chipped paint here and
that looks really awesome and we can
blend those two together
yeah I really like that that looks
really really nice let's see if we can't
blend them together with a a mix node
here let's grab that and we're gonna
throw in texture one texture too and
then throw the mix note in to normal and
hopefully we should get something that
is yeah between the two of them I like
that a lot
awesome let's clean this up a little bit
wonderful
very very cool okay so we have a nicely
like texture on this tank I'm gonna
smooth out this gradient a bit awesome
awesome
all right what's next we let's let's
apply the bump maps that go along with
these normal maps for even more detail
so I'll apply the same because basically
these two match right these images match
it's coming from the same texture so I'm
going to apply the same projection and
transform and I'll pipe that into the
bump tab there and that should give us a
bit more detail even more detail and
I'll do the same for the other the other
texture and mix them again as well so
I'll grab a mix node and you can see
guys you can see how this is kind of
getting a little crazy that's just how
it is that's how texturing is man it
gets pretty intense
awesome we can invert those two if you
want the bump to go in instead of out
well that kind of counteracts the normal
a little bit personally I kind of like
it without the bump I think just what
the normal is fine how's everybody doing
how is the stream going
let's check in what up son Carl what's
up Carl how you doing man tank looking
juicy ah let's hit that dirt node yeah
let's get into that dirt node next Ruth
wick Greg's all Greg's all the guy
behind a char Haven and node Wrangler
add-on and Blender revealed the news
last year and now it's almost done
they're having a contest now for book
textures go check it out no hgri Haven I
think they do like free HDR eyes for
lighting your your scene and stuff okay
Ralph says the normal just tells the
computer to bounce light depending on
the green and red colorings on the map
itself if green make if green make light
if red make dark etc yeah yeah and I
think it actually goes on like normal
goes up down left and right bump just
goes up and down as far as far as I know
Oh boss can't donate well shoot me and I
gotta get that figured out then we will
get that figured out for next time
but I appreciate you dude if you guys
are looking to to help support I
actually do have a website and some of
you guys probably most of you guys know
this by now but I do have a photography
website where I post all my film and
digital photography from around the
world I've been to Japan China Indonesia
Beijing Taiwan Ireland most
recently if you go to the collections
tab you can search all the different
places yeah I got a lot of cool photos
here I try to get the prices down as
cheap as I could for you guys free
shipping on orders over 100 bucks but I
just put up this newfoundland photo
series here it's all foggy and stuff and
then I got Japan I got Shanghai and
Ireland they look really beautiful I
actually just shipped out three photos
for people who they ordered from last
week's stream and I really appreciate
you guys but yeah that's a way to
support right now unfortunately I guess
I don't have the donation thingy set up
here on the stream I didn't even know
that was a thing but yeah thanks guys I
appreciate you let's keep going here on
this on this uh on this texture now okay
so alright let's try and get the dirt
node going so basically this is like my
favorite part the scratch metal and the
dirt node so if you guys ever look at
say anything you left outside if you
look at like an old car or if you look
at um let's see if we can't get like a
Google image to show you this reference
I'm talking about but basically things
get dirty and dirt and dust gets in the
cracks and crevices and actually here's
a great example I have my film camera
right here and if you guys can see right
up in there and this is the webcam so
it's not focusing but up in here there's
a bunch of like there's a bunch of dirt
you know it's dirty around this ring and
it's dirty inside of this little crevice
here the same goes for like if you look
closely there's like a bunch of dirt
collected up in here and around here so
that's kind of what we want to
simulate with this tank because it's
been going through a bunch of mud and
stuff right so it's gotta be dirty
all right so how do we do that
octane has a really really cool thing
called a dirt node and that would be
let's see let's find that for you guys
the dirt node is just off to the left
here it's just as dirt let's drag that
out here and let's apply it to the
diffuse tab so we can actually see what
we're doing right and you'll notice
pretty quickly here if you take the
strength and crank it to ten you can see
how there is you know the corners the
crevices start to get this like you know
a dark ring around them let's zoom in
and take a look take a closer look here
this is a good example so anywhere
there's like a little crevice or a crack
the dirt node fills in with black right
so what does that mean for us that
basically means that you can put any
other texture in place where that black
is you know just like the roughness map
we were dealing with or the bump Maps
they're black and white images right
anything that's black you can put
something into that spot anything that's
white you can either put nothing or
something into that spot so let's tweak
this a little bit and give you guys a
quick example of what this would look
like so the strength is up to ten let's
crank the radius to two maybe even three
heck maybe even four and you can see how
we're getting stuff here like these
lines we don't like I think that's a
tolerance slider the tolerance slider
would fix that so take that to like
point one and yeah sure enough that
disappeared it's basically like how how
how potent do you want it you know do
you want it to hit every
crack and crevice or is it just you know
like the pretty obvious cracks and
crevices
now this dirt note is cool too because
you can use it for an altar for an
alternate purpose right now we're using
it for like a dirt you know a dirt pass
we're gonna fill this with with like a
dirt texture if you hit invert normal
it's gonna get the edges and this will
be very useful for scratches and stuff
because if you look at anything that
you've used put a lot of love into
there's a lot of scratches and and all
that stuff on the outside on the edges
of things so we'll get to that in a
minute but let's deal with the dirt
texture itself these little crevices
will uncheck that and let's just grab a
gradient texture and if you hover right
over this little line you can drag and
drop it right in there and the gradient
texture will you know you can set the
colors to whatever you want so let's say
in our case it's orange right or maybe
it is like a dark brown you know it's a
dusty dark brown like that right and
when you zoom out what does our tank
look like it's kind of like if you guys
are ever into if you guys are ever in to
model painting like physically painting
with the paintbrush and stuff you guys
will know of something called a wash and
that's basically black paint and water
mixed together and you brush it over
your your model right if you're into
like Warhammer or something and the the
water right seeps into the cracks and
pushes the paint into those cracks and
that's basically what we're doing here
it's the same exact thing it's just like
a wash over your model and it helps
bring out the details so that's how
we're getting this look right here now
let's keep working on our dirt map and
we'll blend it into the overall texture
that we've been making so far in a
second so let's um let's zoom you zoom
back on in here
right and basically we're gonna do a
couple steps to really make this thing
shine so you got your dirt your dirt
layer here what if we don't want the
dirt in all 100% of the crevices how do
we remove some dirt from say 20% of the
crevices what do we do for that because
it might look too uniform with dirt
everywhere that is a great question I
will show you how to do that right now
so basically how would we do that let's
make a noise map boom let's plug it into
our diffuse just so we can see what
we're doing the projection let's pipe
that projection into there let's crank
up the contrast so we can really see
what's going on and then let's throw the
transform on there how think it's bigger
yes surely it does okay now we got that
set up let's just throw our dirt node
back in okay so we're gonna want to take
away some of the dirt and node and
basically how we're gonna do that is use
I believe a ad I think it's an ad and
you're gonna put the dirt in one and
you're gonna put the noise in another
and hopefully it's gonna take away some
of that dirt yes yes it worked okay so
now you can see how the dirt is only in
certain parts of the tank now right it's
a bit more realistic it's broken up a
bit and again that is I'll show you guys
how I did that
we had our dirt node that we set up we
dragged in an ad node right here right
on the left here and this is very octane
specific but again the same general
rules apply in any other texture
basically you're gonna use one black and
white image to remove some black and
white from another image
so we're gonna drop in that ad and then
we're going to use a noise map here to
decide what is whatever's white is
staying whatever is black is being
removed and then you just drag that into
the diffuse and you have kind of a
broken up a little dirt dirt note here
so let's let's take the contrast back
down so we have a bit more spread right
with the dirt boom yeah that's that's
looking good we can take the octaves to
ten the Omega to one to really like
break up break everything up that's
looking good
that's looking really really really nice
I like that okay so how do we apply this
to the overall let's see the overall
camouflage we did right because right
now it's missing we don't have the dirt
note there anymore
so basically what we'd want to do is go
in here and we're going to combine our
color our little our diffuse or color
pass here with our dirt pass right here
and you're gonna do that with I believe
a multiply so you're gonna pipe 1 into
texture 1 the other end of texture too
and boom right into the into the diffuse
and something happened so what just
happened
hmm you see though you see how it like
you like got all shiny that's weird why
is it doing that
yeah it's getting all bright and stuff
it should just be yeah it should just be
adding the dirt node to that
so maybe multiplies not the right the
right one but I feel like it totally is
why is multiply not working I should
work
I wonder if it's because let's let's try
this let's disable that and instead of
an ad let's try a multiply and we're
gonna multiply this dirt node with the
noise apply that to diffuse okay that
gets us that let's take our noise and
bring the contrast down to like one and
we'll throw a gradient on top of all
that and then multiply and we'll crunch
it and we'll try multiplying that with
our color pass and see if that does
anything okay yeah that actually worked
I kind of don't know why but I guess
that worked and honestly I do get a bit
confused when it comes to what you're
using multiply or add or subtract it
gets a little confusing sometimes
[Music]
welcome Bom dem Bob DOS did I say that
right I don't know welcome I'm glad you
made it at the stream as well
Ralph can you add a black to white color
slider before plugging it into the
specular maybe I kind of I guess I kind
of did that with this gradient here I
crunched it down let's see I'm gonna
want to go back to what I did before I'm
gonna pipe the dirt and the noise into
an ad and then from there let's see that
should give us that broken up kind of
feel and then from the ad let's see yeah
you see that's broken up in the corners
let's do a basically like a levels on
that will crunch that down whole bunch
yeah like that and then let's try that
into the multiply on the diffuse yeah
that works
Ralph thank you that's what I needed I
needed to put a gradient on this ad here
and just crunch it down so it was a bit
more contrasty sweet heck yeah I think
it looks really really nice it is a bit
bit dark so I think I'll walk this back
a little bit awesome
and then you can also go back and adjust
your original gradient we set this to a
brown you could you could be setting
this to a yellow or a green right and
it's gonna change that but we're gonna
want that that Brown awesome so now we
have the the crevasses you know filled
in on this tank and around the bolts and
stuff like a lot of a lot of grunge's
has worked in there and we can even
expand so it's pretty sharp right you
can see that's pretty sharp if we go
back and we adjust our overall gradient
that is controlling the the contrast and
the crunch of that we can kind of bring
these open a little bit so it's not so
extreme something like that and we can
adjust the the noise because the noise
is what's giving us that like that
grunge and that crunch so where's the
noise there's our noise right there you
just take the the contrast down if we
did contrast of zero it's more of a
solid bar but if you want to kind of add
that that crunchy grungy look to the
inside you work that up and then yeah
there you got that you can also work
your dirt node and you can take your
radius and set that to ten - and that
will really kind of get in there and
that's not looking too bad
mmm let's go back to the noise bring it
down a little bit and go to the dirt
node and let's hit the radius even more
so you're really kind of getting like a
nice light grunge up in those corners
there
I think that's looking pretty good sweet
you can take it to the max we can go to
the max here on this we can take that
dirt node and make the radius like 50
and that'll kind of get you a more wash
out look there but at this point we
would probably want to use a texture
versus like a that's not bad though
that's all--that's that's not that bad
it's very it's very textured right it
has that look to it I like it
okay so that's the dirt node instead of
a color you can also just have it be a
texture as well and that you would just
replace the let's see what would you
replace then we're getting into mixed
textures I guess at that point but you
would still use your dirt node you would
use basically this whole node here this
this like little tree we made and we
would use it on a mixed texture which I
will get to here in a second because
that's what we're gonna need to actually
scratch away this paint to reveal the
metal on the inside so let's try that
what is the base of a tank look like
what is like the pre coat of a tank or
what's the pre coat of a car it'd be
some sort of like steel I guess right a
steel texture and let's see what mega
scans has as far as steel goes mega ganz
dot s E and let's just type in steel and
see what they have
that's cool but it'd be pretty easy to
make steel in in octane so let's do it
let's do it all right so we're gonna
make a whole new material let's name
this one camo we'll make a new glossy
material and octane we'll apply it to
our entire tank and let's go into that
let's go to the index and the index
basically controls how reflective your
tank is if you set it to one it's gonna
be like a chrome kind of mirror it's
basically a mirror right and that's what
we'll do for now we'll set it to one so
you're dealing with just a chrome object
and we will start to put in a bit of
texture to this so I'm gonna use those
Cornelius Dom wreck textures and I'll
show you guys where you can get those
let me let me get a link down for you
guys here on this page I'm gonna include
it in the chat here he has some free
down loadable tile able glossy maps and
that's what i'm using right here this
guy right here he's got some free tile
displacement maps as well good stuff
amazing artist he's like actually you
guys may have seen some of his art
before you guys have seen like this
image here or if you have seen this
image here it's actually the picture
that octane uses when you boot it up so
that's Cornelius he's amazing
all right let's use some of his maps
we'll use both of those fingerprint ones
here we'll drag them in and we will mix
them with a multiply node one two
I know I'm gonna need to mess with the
projection so I'm gonna hit projection
let's see you can also drag the
projection in it's gonna be same for
both we'll set it to box it will set
that to the diffuse tab so we can see
what we're doing but actually diffuse it
doesn't sorry I'm just gonna I'm moving
too fast all right that's what we're
looking like it's in terms of the smudge
let's let's throw transform on this guy
and rotate it just a random number of
points here and that will be our
roughness tab and take the index back to
one and now you guys can see how the
roughness is working here some stuff is
like chromed out and most of it but most
of it is rough and if you want to fix
that if you want to kind of tweak that
you can come in here and adjust the you
can select both images and adjust the
gamma all together and you can see how
that kind of like starts to open things
up you get a bit more contrast in that
so I like that
the gamma up a little bit let's just
take it to five and let's throw a
gradient on the end of this chain
because what we're gonna do is take the
white and instead of white we're gonna
take it down to like half gray
but really what I'm looking for is this
chromed out part it's too chrome for me
so I'm going to take the black and go
like a dark gray and you see how that
kind of give you more of a realistic
look there
so what we're what are we using this for
I don't even remember oh yeah we're
making our steel we're making our steel
texture here so we're close we're very
close let's give the steel a bit of
texture to it just like we did with the
normal map let's do the same here um we
want to like scratch this thing up so
let's do we can use some mega scans
imperfections they have a bunch of
scratched metal stuff so that's a bit
intense that could actually be pretty
sweet
let's try this
and again I'm getting these from mega
scans dot-com you might be our mega
scans dot se you can get from polygon
and I think some of you guys have have
dropped some links down here as well for
some free texture sites
okay so basically yeah you have the we
have our normal there let's bring that
into the bump map and that jacked
everything up let's get the projection
right so we'll make a little projection
node we'll set the texture projection to
XYZ to uvw you can see how it's getting
a little streaky on the side we'll just
set it to box box works most of the time
here now you see how it's like really
gotten rid of our reflectivities ear if
you take the power of this down to zero
it's basically you're just turning it
off so let's um let's take the power of
that just a half or even 0.25 and I
think that's gonna give it that's gonna
give it like a nice little like
scratched up look yeah that's looking
pretty sweet very nice and we don't need
to go too detailed on this we don't need
to do like the dirt or anything because
our our paint layer actually has the
dirt this is just what we're gonna see
when we scratch away the paint and we'll
do that with a mixed texture so we have
this right down on the bottom left we
have our camo you guys saw we did that
boom
that's our camo and honestly I kind of
want to make the camo a bit more
reflective so I'm gonna go to roughness
and bring that down a bit but okay so we
have a roughness texture attached to it
so that roughness slider doesn't really
work let's grab that gradient at the end
of our texture chain and see what we're
dealing with here but what if we take
the black and we turn it to white
what does that do not much if we do that
for both what if we make them both black
not much either okay
let's see what if we crank the gamma on
these
what if we take off man I'm getting a
little little crunchy here it's going a
little slow
take off the roughness oh no guys we
crashed ooh God dang it we crashed y'all
it happens that's why you save often so
you save frequently all right Nick I've
been using basic c40 for a few months
now and I've been considering getting
octane does anyone here feel like using
octane gave them more freedom when
creating their art I know it's important
to have the basic skills down before
investing money and equipment slash
software I'm just curious how big a
difference it is made for some so Nick
great question I avoided octane for the
longest time because I literally was
trying to do exactly what you're doing
which was uh learning the basics first
and I was learning what was I learning I
was learning the physical renderer and
rn8 Corridor was for the longest time I
was like dude use octane switch to
octane switch to octane because he was
using it all the time and I'm like no I
want to learn the basics I want to learn
physical renderer first before I do this
and he's like dude trust me trust me and
eventually I got into octane and it was
the best decision I've ever made and it
doesn't matter if you get octane or
Arnold or redshift
they're all gonna be awesome they're all
gonna be way better than physical
renderer they're gonna render so much
faster you have this live window down
here right where you get to see what
you're doing quickly and you have a lot
of really cool tools like you have
camera tools you can you know adjust the
bloom and everything and it's really
cool it's a really really cool renderer
but I do suggest upping if you're ready
to take the next step do that do up to
another renderer it will improve your
game you'll be moving a lot faster and I
think your render quality and your
render times will improve tenfold
okay let's just get back to - mixing
these two textures together we have our
camouflage and we have our steel so
let's name these accordingly camo and
steel so you can do this a couple ways
you can go to materials and the octane
render live viewer tab here and you can
make a octane mix material and basically
what that's going to do is give you a
mix material here and you have a couple
options if you select the mixed material
down here in your window you'll see
material one and material two and you
can click and drag your steel and drag
your camo and now when you apply your
octane mix material to your tank you're
gonna see you'll have a mixture of
between the two and right now it looks a
bit more reflective than it does camo
but it is a 50/50 split right now that
we don't want that we don't want that so
let's go in let's see what we can do
let's go into the node editor and you
see what I mean guys you see how this
can quickly fill up here and get really
confusing so let's auto arrange all this
stuff it's gonna get confusing so you're
gonna want to be organized this does not
look organized this looks very confusing
to me
so let's find our base material here we
have camo let's select the hierarchy of
camo okay that goes over there alright
we got that and then now we have the
steel let's right-click that select that
hierarchy we can move that over here
we're left with our mixed material boom
there it is
that's what we want and we have it looks
like a rogue image there and a rogue
multiply there okay save off and save
frequently guys
okay so we have a mix material and we
can see it's over our tank right now and
we have this float texture the float
texture is basically saying it's set to
0.5 right and it's saying mix these two
materials fifty-fifty right down the
middle if we set the float to zero it'll
be the camo if we set the float to 1
it's gonna be our steel and it defaults
at 0.5 50/50 and in real quick just
another way for you guys if you if you
didn't get that mixed material set up
properly again you do that by going to
your octane live viewer right up here
and you go to materials and you make an
octane mix material you have make sure
you have the material selected down here
and you should have this tab here your
mix material tab you'll have material
one and material two you can drag your
steel and your camo into those little
slots and you'll be good to go
another way of doing it is over here
when you're in your node view you can go
up to the very very top and you can make
an octane mixed material by dragging
that down and then you can drag your
steel and your camera materials into
that node viewer as well and do it the
same way okay so what here's what we
want remember how before we were using
the dirt node to put dirt in the little
crevasses and then you can hit invert on
that right and you can get the the steel
or your arm sorry you can invert on that
and you can get the node or the dirt
node on the edges and that's what we're
gonna use for this because basically
when you have it on the edges it's as if
we're we're simulating a scratched edge
right let's see if I have anything that
has a scratched edge to it
nothing really obvious oh here we go
actually this this will work so this is
my Sony a7r 2 you can see it on the hot
shoe mount how there's like silver or
there's that like metal edge that's
chipped away from use and it's the same
kind of all around and apologies I'm
just use my webcam for this but you're
having you're having like the undercoat
revealed because something's rubbed up
against that so much right and that is
what we're going to be simulating with
our second dirt node on this tank we're
gonna be revealing the steel underneath
the paint alright so how do we do that
first off let's delete that float node
and let's drag in a dirt node and we're
gonna the the mix material that comes
with a few options you have an amount of
how much to mix it then you have your
material 1 and 2 and your displacement
we're going to be piping our dirt into
the amount and clearly it is not looking
right I think what we want to do is
invert this okay so that's still not
working so now what we need to do is we
need to pipe our steel into material 2
instead so just switch the order of this
if it's not working for you guys just
you can easily switch the order there
you go and now with the dirt let's set
the strength to 10 and ooh baby it looks
like it's working look at that okay now
all we have to do is invert the dirt
node because it's in the cracks we want
it on the edges oh man my computer's
chugging guys
I do my best here okay again you can see
how you can see like the little polygons
the edges there we don't want that so
we're gonna set our tolerance to 0.1
that should get rid of that and when you
hit invert normal you should have your
scratches just on the edges now let's
see it looks like we're getting both for
some reason so what I'm gonna do just to
see clearly here I'm gonna make a new
material I'm gonna throw that new
material on our tank I'm gonna copy our
dirt note here go into our new material
paste it throw it into the diffuse tab
re render the scene so now we don't have
to render a big scene we don't the
render whole bunch of stuff we're just
looking at our dirt node and we are
isolating that piece right so let's work
on this let's see if we can't get this
just on the edges for some reason it's
still in the cracks
so let's invert that let's set the
radius to or less at the details too
like I just start messing with this
stuff
all right so sending the detail to 100
really gets the edge there let's see we
if we take the tolerance to like 0.3
that doesn't help us tolerance to zero
doesn't help if we take the details down
to zero now that doesn't help so I'm
just kind of moving these numbers around
guys to see what we can do
and you know this might be actually be
[Music]
this might actually be because we're
applying this material to the entire
tank whereas we're gonna want to go in
and apply the material just to
individual pieces we want the texture on
so you see how you're getting this edge
here because of the dirt node I bet you
if we were to put this this texture on
just this light bulb thingy let's try it
lantern symmetry let's delete that
headlight symmetry let's see what that
looks like okay so you're still kind of
getting it in the corner there but not
as much you can take our tolerance too
point two
point one
yeah okay so that's that's not the worst
certainly not the worst there
awesome okay let us see here yeah I
think a radius of like 1.5 is good and
for now I'm just gonna put this texture
over the entire tank and we can go in
and we can start applying the texture to
individual pieces at the end cool so
let's take that dirt node let's copy it
let's go back into our octane mix
material well paste it and apply that to
the amount let's render that and see
what we get
Oh what's up to Vaughn yo dude my best
friend's Devon is in the chat right now
what up son he was in cardboard warfare
he was in a couple videos on my channel
a very good friend of mine very good at
Smash Brothers he also come on are you
still streaming Devon was um streaming
some video game stuff recently I was
trying to get back into it
alright so Eric thank you for stopping
by man really appreciate it
come by next time and I hope you learned
a thing or two okay okay
so yeah let's rerender our scene for
some reason it should be oh yeah we need
to apply our material to the tank
awesome
alright so not just okay just like we
did with the dirt node not every single
edge is scratched so we need to chip
away at that with a noise map here and
we'll use this noise map we'll drop it
in there we'll set the contrast to a
hundred let's tweak the mesh UV so
things are uniform that should be good
and we're going to oh I think computer
almost crashed guys that's close one
we're gonna use a multiply node here and
chip away at this dirt node with this
noise map here so that should work in
theory okay see how it's doubling up the
multiply was the wrong one we want a
let's see probably want an ADD
so we dragged the dirt in there the
noise in there throw the amount down
there you go
see how it's it's just scratched and
little pieces there and you set the
noise map we can set the contrast to
like ten and we can even set the dirt
radius to one to really make sure it's
just like very tiny just just little
scratches on the edges there and that
adds a whole lot to the look of this
tank
boom
getting on the edges hopefully up here
yeah it's all scratched up there and you
can adjust your noise map here to see
like how much overall scratching you
want you can kind of like start to
crunch that down so if we go back to the
mixed material dang this computer is
chugging right now I just have one gtx
1070 in this thing so let's see we could
take the gamma of the noise and the
noise it's what's breaking up our
scratched edge here if we take the gamma
down to zero it will disappear if we
take it up you know we'll have the full
scratched edge so you just want to find
that nice balance right in there you can
set the contrast back up try and find
that balance that it feels right for you
guys you can scale the the noise up to
like three and we can set the octave to
one or I'm sorry the octave to ten the
Omega to one that's really gonna like
break up the noise as you can see oh you
should be able to see here it's like
broken up very patchy that feels pretty
good to me and again you can take the
dirt node and bring the radius up to
three if you guys like if that feels
better to you
you can try five but I think that's too
much another thing we want to do is
actually scratch away some of the
surface of this not just the edges so we
can do that with we should be able to do
that with this dirt node as well we can
combo it so let's do
[Music]
so we have this scratched bit here yeah
let's let's do this let's drag that guy
in this from mega scans and let's figure
this out so basically we're stacking a
couple things here now so this couldn't
get a little confusing we have our dirt
node which is sending a black and white
map over our edges we have our noise map
which is taking away some of those edges
to break it up a little bit but now what
we want to do is use this new scratched
layer here to scratch away the surface
of the paint not just the edges so let's
think for a second how would I do this
let's take in a multiply let's take our
dirt and our scratch layer okay
let's solo that is that even soloing
properly I don't even know at this point
here's what I'll do
I'm gonna make this in a new new
material so things aren't so confusing
so I'll apply the new material to the
tank reload our scene okay so we have
our dirt node we know that we want to
use this picture here to also scratch
away some of this surface so we'll use
let's get our scratch node set up we'll
set the projection to box okay and we'll
grab our UV transform I think that's
good for now
let's grab a multiply and throw the dirt
and this image into the multiplied and
there are multiplied into our diffuse so
that way okay we're getting both and if
we use a gradient on all that we can
start to crunch down some of that so you
see how we're getting these scratches in
here as well and then from there we'll
use that noise map to start taking away
some of that so I think that's actually
that's actually working pretty well so
let's copy this here go into our mixed
material we want to keep the noise map
will delete the dirt and add this right
here what we just pasted my computer
works properly let's select that
hierarchy this right here what we just
pasted is our all of our edges and all
of our scratches across the surface like
you guys see right here basically we're
gonna use that and chip away at that
with the noise now so let's see what it
looks like if we just drag that in there
and we need to apply our material and we
render oh yeah there you go you can see
how it's chipped away right there looks
really nice but it's just a bit it's a
bit too uniform obviously not every
single edge would be scratched that's
for sure so we'll go in and we're going
to use that noise map that we'd set up
previously to say you know just keep
some of it not all of it and we'll do
that with I believe in add node
boom drop that in texture one noise goes
into texture too and finally look at
that boom yes it works so we have
scratches over the surface of the tank
which you guys can see here we have
scratches on the edges of the tank yeah
that's that's feeling that's feeling
right to me now if you guys want to go
next level we can keep getting more
detailed with this like we can use a
fall-off map which I'll I will show to
you guys right now but you can use a
fall-off map to basically say I only
want a texture to be on the top of
something or the bottom of something and
let's do it let's make the top of this
thing really dusty and dirty like it's
been sitting for a while alright how's
everybody doing here I've been talking
for a long time we've been going for 2
hours and 11 minutes we're gonna be
wrapping this up soon we're gonna do a
little dirt on top of this thing we'll
make some glass some quick glass for
some of these pieces here and yeah that
basically be yet for this thing we can
keep going but hopefully this should
give you guys an idea of how you can add
and start layering things over this tank
to really make it seem grungy and
crunchy you know
a realistic cardboard tank that's great
yeah you could totally do that certainly
we can do a realistic cardboard tank um
Omega if you want to leave that
suggestion I would say go to the discord
and let me get the link for you real
quick
[Music]
in the discord here you guys can join
that and in there let's see we can do
let me drag this for you guys
boom in here on the tutorial suggestions
it looks like you arty you guys have
done some suggestions so thank you just
leave a suggestion down here in the
tutorial tutorial suggestions tab and
we'll see what you guys want you start
voting on stuff I'll read all this and
whatnot
we got stream suggestions do something
on substance designer like you talked
about on the stream sweet now
technically that should go in the
tutorial suggestions but I could see how
that'd be a little confusing I'll
probably tweak those a little bit but
heck yeah you guys are awesome let's
keep going let's get this let's let's
get this thing dirty let's get this
thing dirty you know real quick real
quick let's just add some grunge to this
tank to the to the diffuse pass right we
want to diffuse when I say anymore guys
I'm losing my mind over here just saying
words okay you see this camo not dirty
enough guys we need to get a little
dirtier with this camo so how are we
gonna do that
hopefully my computer is going to
survive the last of this so we have our
diffuse section here let's select the
hierarchy all of these little nodes are
are controlling the color of this tank
oh here comes the crash here comes oh my
god here comes I don't think we're gonna
survive this one guys I really don't you
know you got the blue spinning wheel
it's not good I'm at the force quit this
thing hmm
I need another video card I mean like at
another GTX I have what I have a 1017
year but boy oh boy we got a lot of
textures going you know what the force
quit this guy
apologies sometimes it happens you know
sometimes it happens all right let's go
back in for a final run we're gonna
crunch the tank up we're gonna put like
a layer of dust and dirt on the top of
this tank and then we'll render it out
at a really cool angle it's almond time
you guys got your snacks
all right how long do you think it's
gonna take me to get through all this
very Alma's I only eat him on the stream
maybe we can get through these together
we'll see okay so sometimes I have to
pause my live view err cuz it gets a
little too intense so I'm gonna do that
right now we're gonna add a fall-off map
to basically say that uh you know we
want dirt on the top of this tank and
not anywhere else just on the parts that
are facing the sky so let's just make a
new sequence here to give you guys an
idea of what I'm talking about so if I
made one of these little pull trapezoid
thingies and we make a new diffuse
material drop it on there let's go in
and instead of a dirt map we're gonna
use a fall-off map and that's right
right underneath it right there drag
that in drag in that's it into the
diffuse and by default you can see here
it comes in basically saying anything on
the outside edge is white anything on
the inside is black and this is actually
really good for um like car paint you
can say it's you see those like speckles
on a car paint you can see them on the
outside but not when you're looking at
it directly on right if you go to the
fall-off map you can change this mode
and write deep by default it's set to
normal versus IRA which is that kind of
you know everything on the edge is a
certain color and everything in the
middle is black but if you set it to
ninety degrees here you can see how
everything on top is black and
everything on the bottom is white and
hopefully by now you guys have realized
if you can get a black-and-white image
and have control over a black and white
image on your model you can basically
put anything in place of black and
anything in place of white so this is
good because now we can say let's put
wherever there's black let's put dirt or
dust and wherever there's white let's
you know just leave normal let's just
leave as the normal tank with a multiply
node or something
so okay you guys member that almond dust
yeah it's it's the thing okay
so let's copy this fall-off map and
paste it on our tank let's go into the
mix material here
paste it in there and just just to get
the idea I'll put it on the amount
between our steel and our camo what what
happened to our tank well there we go so
you can see like everything that's white
it is uh is just the camo but everything
that's black is God dang it this is
almond does hold on I got some water
I'll bear back
it's dirty this thing up we need to make
a dirt texture right so we could either
do that through mega scans or we could
do it ourselves but I think since you
know since I've been making textures on
this stream and for the sake of time I'm
gonna make I'm just gonna grab something
from mega scans here and let's find
something I'll just type in dirt and
should have some good stuff in here
I love this website so much
all right so this is like pretty intense
so it's a lot of dirt but heck let's try
it
but download that guy alright I'll show
you guys real quick how to uh how to
apply this that's downloading so um I'll
start with a glossy material I'll drag
that onto our sphere come in here and
basically we're gonna start just
dragging and dropping some images and
pasting them into certain parts of you
know to their respective places so let's
unpack this folder or just finish the
download all right
great here we go so an albedo map is
basically just the diffuse or the color
so you guys can see there it's a dirt
texture but it's very glossy and I'm
gonna just crank up those segments next
we will do will drag and drop the bump
map put it into the little bump tab and
you can see how that's gonna like you
know start to shape this thing well we
have a gloss map here and that's gonna
go into actually we're gonna use gloss
we're gonna use roughness drag that into
there and you can see this thing
starting to get shaped out right and
then we have specular which is what is
shiny and what is not shiny and I'm
guessing yep it's not very shiny we have
an AO pass which is basically like an
ambient occlusion pass for the crevices
and stuff and you're gonna use a
multiply node to mix those together
right the diffuse and the a/o together
give you like an ambient occlusion pass
and you can tweak the settings of that
by cranking the gamma on the ambient
occlusion you can see these like little
gaps getting filled and stuff right in
there I like that what else we have the
normal the normal map and that's going
to add a lot of detail to our texture
and the last thing we need to do is just
adjust the mapping the UV mapping on
this so I'm going to select one and hit
the projection and I'm gonna just pipe
this into all of the projection tabs on
all of these images and I really wish
octane had the ability to like select
all of these and then just hit
projection and it was all in each one
just had its own that'd be really nice
but there you can see our mapping is a
bit better now actually no I totally
lied totally made that up because I
actually change it forgot to change it I
set it to XYZ to uvw and I think this
will work for what we're doing that
mapping will work for what we're doing
so basically I can just call this dirt
and we will copy this edit copy we'll go
to our tank project and we will paste it
into that project once it loads
oh let's give that a little peace
boom
man this computers chug in Oh scary so
scary
alright so let's see we want to combine
this mix material with another mixed
material and just have it be use a
fall-off map to separate the two
materials so once again we'll go to
material octane mixed material we're
gonna throw our dirt into material one
our mix material in the material - and
let's hop into the mix material real
quick and change that fall-off map we
need to put it back to the scratches
like how we had it you know then let's
go to let's see let's copy our new that
fall-off map that we made let's go into
our new mix material and make sure you
apply the new mix material to your tank
update scene and that actually kind of
gives it a cool like dirty look to it
yeah that's that's awesome I don't even
mind mind that damn much and we can we
can we can tweak it I'll show you guys
in a second here alright look at this
mess look at this just spider web of
nonsense here whoa okay start pushing
and pulling stuff if you right-click and
hit select hierarchy you can start
moving stuff oh man that's a lot it's a
lot guys oh goodness oh goodness
select hierarchy for the steel get that
[Music]
man the dirt does just not want to be
selected
we got camo
why does that not want to be selected I
don't I have no idea
select the hierarchy there
let's auto arrange it there we go so we
can see what we're doing this is our
master mix node here
I believe no the master makes notice
here and we're mixing this mix with this
dirt and we want to do it with this fall
off hopefully this is making sense to
you guys it's kind of a little
complicated that's why you want to stay
organized okay if we solo that fall off
map we can see here that the top is
black and it's going to gray and then
this stuff that it's vertical is white
so we'll disable that and we should the
camo on top should be invisible unless
it's the other way around okay
yeah totally so the other way around we
just need to invert this fall off map so
if we do let's throw a gradient on it
and flip these tabs around
that'll invert it and the mapping is off
right you can see the mapping doesn't
make sense so we need to go to the
texture projection on our dirt node and
just change that to like box or
something and that looks a bit better
I wonder if X Y Z DUV W works nope box
it is
sweet
and now if you go to that fall-off map
that we made there's that gradient map
attached to it and if we want some dirt
on these white parts you can just change
the white to kind of an off-white and
dirt will fall into place right there
and eventually if you work that all the
way down oh we're taking it away okay
okay the other way around take the black
set the black to dark gray and then
you'll start seeing that in the white
sections here right until eventually the
whole thing if you set it to white the
eventually the whole thing is covered in
dirt which we don't want just a little
bit and then you can even take the white
and set it to a light white or a light
gray to kind of take some of that dirt
off the top because it's not completely
covered in dirt and the bottom right
would be clean or you can throw mud up
underneath it or something but yeah
that's the idea there that's the idea
you could um you could go into the color
tab here on the camouflage let's see if
we can't get in here and let's grab like
a grunge texture something from mega
scans you know we can do it we can do an
overall grunge across the whole thing so
let's see mega scans imperfections
grunge and we have some grunge Maps here
like this but that's a little too like
when you tile this thing you're really
gonna see that's that circle right here
and we don't want that so we want
something a bit more uniform this is not
bad that's pretty specific so I'll go
with the middle one I'll go with this
one right here
and we'll use that with a mix note here
so I'm gonna use a mix node to mix our
camouflage and a let's see
well mix our camouflage and I'm gonna
grab a RGB texture or an RGB spectrum
from up here and we'll just for the sake
of the tutorial here we'll just turn
this black and we're gonna mix between
this camel you're seeing here and this
black texture by by by means of this
image right here so whatever's black
will be black whatever it's gray will be
in between it members white will will
just be our camo and we can really push
and pull that here so let's make sure
our projection is right for that usually
you want to set it to box let's scale it
up so we'll add a UV transform to it
and we'll set it to like three let's
solo it so we see what we're doing okay
and then let's let's throw a gradient on
it to really add some contrast to that
grunge so we'll disable that we'll come
in here and we'll scale we'll just
crunch these together and you can see
how now
there's like this little grungy stuff
all over the tank and we can we can kind
of push and pull that gradient there to
really get a nice look yeah just like
that
yeah so that's basically that's
basically it for the tank and this is
pretty intense we can take down I think
the dirt that grunge layer we can take
down our dirt layers we can take down as
well I'd probably spend another hour or
so on this really tweaking this I think
it's a little overkill but you guys get
the idea I'm gonna keep working on this
I think we can throw in some like glass
for the headlights here and for this
little piece up here we can also do some
dark glass for this here let's just do
that real quick if you make a glossy
material and we go in here and we want
to select this piece I believe it's just
a plain that I had set up there should
be a plain behind there
yeah this plane right here is our little
window and you can totally just go in
here set this to like diffuse to black
and now it's just kind of like a little
window you can add your roughness to
that so it's kind of a scratched window
or a grungy window same for here you
know you'd want to apply it to this
little piece on the turret it looks like
it's just what is that piece okay so
that doesn't work
you'd basically need to make like
separate geometry for that little
underneath piece and same for here you
know if you want to get these windows to
be darker you would select your geometry
and select your polygons and I'm just
holding down shift and rotating clicking
these little windows and then you should
be able to drag-and-drop your texture
onto those and that should work I don't
know why that didn't work oh it's
because so here's why it's because we
have our overall texture applied to this
whole thing this whole tank it's like
your top folder has a texture applied to
it so any textures you apply below that
are gonna be over over written by the
main texture so you'd have to go in here
and start detailing and picking the
pieces you want to be exactly what so
that would that would just take a lot of
time and certainly can be done I just
don't think we have time on the stream
to do that but yeah again I think it's a
little extreme but you can walk these
textures back you can work your work
your settings back I think it was a
little bit better without this dirt I
think it's too much because then now you
don't really see the scratches in the in
the camo which I really liked
whoo man that was a stream that was a
stream lots of textures so um let's see
Zorin that I miss any announcements
other than the discord I was at a
pottery throwing class pottery chucking
Potter against the wall are you making
pottery interesting Guillermo yeah you
can totally separate the mesh and make a
new material absolutely absolutely
totally a good way of doing that but
yeah oh yeah as far as announcements go
yeah we have the discord it's in the
chat here a little earlier I mentioned
that I had a website I'm selling
photography prints if you guys want to
support in the meantime this is a good
way of doing so photography film and
digital from around the world try to get
these prices as low as I could for you
guys we got free shipping on orders over
a hundred bucks I do want to make some
VFX materials and assets for you guys I
want to make some free stuff I want to
do some cheap stuff like some you know
$5 texture pack or something or some
grunge packs for you guys to to mess
with but in the meantime this is a good
way to help out with the with the
photography here let's see anything else
guys anything else thank you again for
stopping by that was really fun
texturing that tank with you guys
voy de asks if I have a cool playlist of
chill songs that I use on Instagram
sometimes I don't but I will make one
I've actually been talking about doing
that well it with Nick at corridor we're
all talking about doing our own
playlists and everything so that's
definitely something I would like to
have for the next stream is a playlist
for you guys and if you guys have any
progress that you want to post go out to
the discord and there's a little
progress thing there tutorial progress
post it in there right here project
progress and let's just keep critiquing
each other's stuff let's keep growing
and learning together that's the whole
point of all this right thanks again
guys for joining the stream and thanks
again for being super active in this
thing really appreciate you guys and
until next time I will see y'all next
week hopefully around the same time
Saturday if you guys like this time
Saturday at noon PST if a little later
if it works better for you then let me
know in the discord but cool thanks guys
peace